c'est une première depuis six ans pour
un chef d'état français nicolas sarkozy
est en visite officielle à damas après
les rapprochements de juillet dernier la
france veut consolider ses relations
avec la syrie et par là même peser sur
les négociations de paix au proche
orient sur place pour france 3 stéphane
grand guillaume barbier une marseillaise
qui résonnent aux portes du palais
présidentiel
six ans qu'un président français n'avait
foulé le sol syrien isolé jusque là une
nouvelle ère s'ouvre notamment pour
damas car pour paris la syrie a donné
des signes encourageants notamment sur
le dossier libanais résultats en juillet
bachar el assad était invité à paris
pour le lancement de l'union pour la
méditerranée l'acte 2 aujourd'hui qui
commence par un échange d'amabilités
nous construisons pas à pas une relation
que nous voulons confiante pour tourner
la page des désaccords il y a bien sûr
le liban mais aussi les négociations
actuelles entre la syrie et israël les
dossiers ne manquent pas nicolas sarkozy
va en profiter pour réaffirmer sa
position sans concession vis-à-vis du
nucléaire iranien l'amie et l'alliée
indéfectible de la syrie l'iran ne doit
pas posséder l'armé nucléaire
l'arme nucléaire pour l'iran c'est une
menace pour la paix de la région et pour
la paix du monde
la réponse de bachar el assad sera toute
diplomatique
à la mi-temps on a pu la syrie a
retrouvé la vue que le dossier nucléaire
iranien et biens civils mais voilà et
non militaire c'est donc un pari
diplomatique osé pour nicolas sarkozy
adepte on le sait de la rupture la
france veut remettre dans le jeu la
série pourtant isolé sur la scène
internationale depuis 2004 le régime de
bachar el-assad est effectivement un
allié stratégique de l'iran est un
fidèle soutien du hezbollah au liban